let's get to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 and see what's on people's minds
let's go first to our caller today from
the three-two-three area code caller
from 3 to 3 what's your name where you
calling from
hey David does just live right now in
Miami yes what's your name where you
calling from my name is Enrique I'm
calling from Los Angeles California
great what's on your mind today
hey I just wanted to I've always thought
had this feeling that as as leftist
Democrats progressives whatever you want
to call it you know people are not gonna
vote for Trump
I really think we should unify more I
kind of feel like the Republicans are
really really good at always coming
together at the end and that's why they
win I really feel like I listen to a lot
of progressives on the shooting on
Canada ever sorry okay that's okay
I listen to look I listen to a lot of
progressives I like yourself and
everybody else on YouTube and all that
stuff and sometimes I feel like we're
just too divisive amongst each other and
we're too picky I think about things and
I just think we should focus on coming
together you know we don't want what
happened in 2016 to happen again we're
all Bernie voters a lot of them voted
for Trump you know what I mean I see
sometimes yeah you're just right I mean
you're just right and I've talked about
this listen the online divisive nessam
Ungh the left I did a story earlier this
week about how I'm considering leaving
social media altogether because it is so
toxic and counterproductive that it is
it's just a cesspool it's disgusting and
and it's quite frankly embarrassing I
mean yeah the right is vile online but
you're right that in the end they just
come together and vote now there's a
balance to be struck between we want to
lobby for and support candidates that
are actually progressive and that
support our values and during the
primary a spirited evaluation of the
candidates makes sense and we want to do
it but where it goes off the rails is
number one when these sort of internal
divisive neskowin
what makes sense and you're pointing
that out and number two when it gets to
the general election
anybody who argued in 2016 that Hillary
would have been just as bad as or even
worse than Trump if you have a left-wing
perspective it's just not true Hillary
is too far in the middle for me I don't
disagree with that she's a centrist
Democrat but look at what happened to
the Supreme Court look at what happened
to international relations with our
allies so I'm just as worried as you are
Enrique yeah and yeah exactly and thanks
so much and also one last thing is I
really think we also need to learn how
to speak the general language of America
like ice-t Trump he talks to people at
their level he talks to America at their
level I keep hearing Bernie which I love
of course yeah keeps using the word
austerity let's let's bring the
austerity that the working-class no one
else is there insert stop using those
words yeah we don't know what you're
talking about
listen I don't either model now let's be
careful Enrique I don't want to advocate
for the dumbing down of issues either
why right but not dumbing down yeah what
lateral appeals to people and and this
is I mean you're just you're you're
you're right and this gets to issues of
framing that there's a lot of good
writing about issues of framing and a
yeah point absolutely well made yeah
yeah and you know what the last thing
your great I love your show I listen
like I said to a lot of progressives
online and I kind of went through
YouTube and I unsubscribe to a bunch of
them because they were just too much for
me really and what I love about your
show yeah yeah because you know you know
you know we have lives we've got to work
with our stuff you know but and you're
me only have so much energy in your mind
right yeah choo choo listen to people's
up but I love your show because you're
calm and you're not I don't know if I
can really explain it but the way you
talk about things gives me comfort and
and I understand them and NADP okay all
right and recap thank you very much I
really appreciate your call we will be
putting Enrique in is a good caller in
the system we could hear him he got
right to his questions and of course he
heaped completely undeserved praise on
to me so very very good